very popular las vegas mexican
restaurant closing its doors
and it could be shuttered for up to a
year maybe even longer
the original lindo michiwa khan located
on desert in near eastern
is going through some major problems not
only has the pandemic affected business
but now a sinkhole has severely damaged
the building
8 news now reporter sally jaramillo is
live tonight just outside the restaurant
with more
yes he is owner javier barajas is still
in shock he can't believe this is
happening
he's also devastated that he has to lay
off employees but he's grateful
that no one got hurt now i do want to go
ahead and show you all of the damage
where all of this
definitely occur take a closer look the
sinkhole
was caused by a leaking pipe and to fix
it it's going to take a while
javier barajas is the owner of all three
lindo michoacans in the valley
his restaurant has been named the best
mexican restaurant for the last
20 years i never you know
expected you know to be like my
restaurant be this famous
on saturday november 14 he received some
bad news
i was in another restaurant and my
daughter called me and say hey dad
the floor started cracking and popping
off i came over and i noticed that
the floor was a thinking everyone inside
had to leave immediately we didn't know
exactly what was wrong if it was the
roof or the floor or the walls i mean we
don't have no idea
the cause a water leak right now the
the general contractor and the plumbers
are looking for all the uh leaks and
trying to find out
you know the the problems and see if we
can save the
the building very very sad especially
because
we have almost 90 employees that we have
to lay
off and we don't know if they're going
to find jobs
soon many of his employees have been
with him since day one
and have shared the good and the bad
there is three events that i never gonna
forget
you know 2008 the rotation
when he born down in 2002 and
did one despite the challenges he says
they only make him stronger this is our
baby you know this is
far las vegas
expects this location to be back open in
a year he also
asked the las vegas community tonight to
please support your local restaurants
that's either by
delivery or takeout and give
certificates for now reporting live
sally jaramillo 8 news now